qué supone el anuncio de bukele de
lanzarse a la reelección
Mira este creo que es parte del libreto
el mismo libreto que usó Chávez y que
han usado otros
déspotas autoritarios en la región para
buscar
perpetuarse en el poder una nada más que
eso ese es una operación relativamente
sencilla
que le logró
controlar el poder judicial y como tú
decías Andrés en esta introducción
una sala especializada de la Corte
Suprema hace un año
le dio luz verde para postularse a la
reflexión a pesar de que el texto
explícito de la constitución del
Salvador lo prohíbe
ahora su aspiración se puede considerar
como una violación del Estado de derecho
como dicen los críticos Como chocan el
fallo de la Corte Suprema que le permite
ser aspirante y lo que dice la
Constitución
mira lo que ocurre es lo siguiente eh
hace poco más de un año porque le logró
el control total del Congreso
y valiéndose de ese control descabezó a
los jueces de la Corte Suprema que eran
bastante independientes y que
resguardaban el espíritu y la letra de
la Constitución y la Constitución es
absolutamente inequívoca en este punto
un presidente electo que ya está en
funciones no puede aspirar a un segundo
periodo sin embargo esa nueva
sala de la Corte Suprema con jueces
afines a ukele decidió por sí Y ante sí
darle una interpretación
yo diría Absurda y contraria al al texto
literal de la y abrir las puertas para
que buquele se postulara nuevamente algo
que lo anunció el día de ayer y
Lamentablemente Reproduce replica lo que
es usual en en otros casos en América
Latina donde
mandatarios que son electos
democráticamente luego persiguen
quedarse en el poder y violar normas
elementales del Estado derecho y de la
propia Constitución ahora señor Vivanco
busqué le justificó ayer su guerra
contra las pandillas diciendo que está a
punto de ganar la cual es el verdadero
balance o la verdadera intención detrás
de esta política según usted
Mira Andrés las pandillas
las maras en El Salvador son un problema
real
están compuestas por
delincuentes que cometen asesinatos
extorsiones torturas reclutamiento de
menores es decir son una organización
criminal de alto peligro pero sin
embargo lo que busqué le ha decidido
hacer es olvidarse del Estado derecho
del poder judicial de las normas claves
que existen para evitar abusos Y ha
dicho redadas con la policía para
capturar a todo aquel que pareciera ser
integrante de una de estas pandillas y
con eso en los últimos meses a duplicado
la población carcelaria en en El
Salvador uno se Pregunta cuántos de esos
que están en prisión son efectivamente
miembros de estas pandillas y cuántos
son absolutamente inocentes
bukele con esta política anti delictiva
anti pandillas ha cometido masivas y muy
graves violaciones a los derechos
fundamentales en El Salvador